foreign
[Music]
and today we'll be reviewing the Samsung
order CR this is very different from the
traditional videos that I usually do I
mean I've covered LG Alienware Samsung
themselves Rog on this channel but this
time this is something totally insane
just look at the size of this thing this
is the Samsung Odyssey art and it's the
biggest display that I've ever had on my
desk right now I've used this for about
two weeks now and I think this might be
the craziest thing that Samsung has ever
done for their the Space Systems what we
have here is a curved display that's 55
inches 4K it is totally everything that
you really really wanted in a TV display
and this is not the entire footing
itself this thing actually flips let me
show you how it actually looks like and
before we get into this big boy right
here here's a word from today's sponsor
this video is brought to you by MSI meet
the summit e16 flip featuring the latest
12th gen Intel Core i7 processor RTX 30
series graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD
Plus touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
Sony e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
there's so much Logistics you need to
figure out as you're actually going
about this Sam had actually contacted me
when I wanted to review this and asked
me if I even had the desk space to even
do this look at me actually having to
lift this up all the way like that
take some string and then after that you
can
flip it like so
boom
look at that that is how we get into the
cockpit mode and you can look all the
way like that
do you really need this I don't think so
but you know what would be great if you
can put two of these side by side then
imagine you can have 4K sideways and 4K
outwards it's actually a square
this is officially the most insane piece
of display tag that I'll be reviewing
this year okay let's get into it so let
me get it back into the normal display
and I'll go bring it through the pieces
of what you actually can look at and
some limitations of why I think this
might be good to show off to your
friends but when they want to use it for
the day today you might be considering
that I don't think it might be something
that you really want to use okay ah let
me bring this up again you can see how I
rotate this go to the back and capture
how I'm rotating it so you can see the
mechanism is very good okay so I've
gotten it back here to this state again
and you can see the display auto
orientates itself and then you have to
push it all the way up or else this
thing will actually lock and you can't
actually even rotate it even if you put
it on a lower angle so I'm gonna push it
down again there we go
it swivels and it goes up and down as
well so you can angle it accordingly to
what you want on your screen let's open
up the game and let's take a look at how
it actually looks like first thing that
really strikes you when you open up
OverWatch yourself
is how bright the screen actually is
look at the size of this thing it looks
great
but if you're seated like that you
really want to focus here but there's so
much peripheral vision and because of
the size and how close I am sitting to
this you need to actually lean back a
bit orientate your entire life around
this thing if you bought it okay right
now I'm in game and you can see then I'm
actually looking very much in center for
the game itself and the tricky part is
because there's so much on the
peripheral vision you're very tempted to
actually look around and this adds on to
quite a bit of next stream especially if
you're playing for long hours I can't
say that this might be the best thing to
fall games especially if you are playing
competitively but it's sure it's very
nice it's very immersive definitely you
can see the curve is really gentle
really brings you in here and I think
um yeah I think this is something that I
really enjoy quite a bit you really have
to see if this actually justifies a
proper purchase in the first place if
you're playing something like low-key
like whatever I'm doing right now for
Magic the Gathering I think it's pretty
straightforward because I've been able
to speed up all these screens all
together and I find that hey it's very
good if you're putting a YouTube video
on one side then after that you're
putting a a game in the middle or
general video editing I think this is
something that people really appreciate
55 inches is something that many people
will read about in general because given
the size of screen putting it on this is
not very viable for everyone
but Samsung itself comes with a proper
Mount and they help you put it all
together in a very nice package and I
think it's very thoughtful conceptually
has a first ever device I think this is
something that Samsung really put in
some thought to actually ensure that
this is something that people actually
want to make use of with the display
itself is the Samsung Odyssey app has a
few options that gives you some
inspiration of how you want to actually
spit out the screens and you can do
multiple viewing windows through the
help of the new back dial remote with
the Samsung Galaxy you're actually
getting two remote controllers what they
call an up down and a regular remote it
is the solar panel you can see them
they're both solar panel but they can be
charged by USB as well over here and
over here I think this is something
that's more interesting for most folks
it's also looks like a calculator right
I mean you go down here you can look at
it here the clicky sound
The Click is very satisfying in itself
is a controller up down left right in
the middle for controls for the power
button back button this is your input
and if you need to see you want to
change your aspect ratios or change out
the entire screen itself you press the
multi-view button and this pops up the
dial itself comes up
so one of the cool things here is with
the up down is that you can change and
resize the scale of the screen
everything is pretty much control here
and not doing multi-view as well just
let me hit this button here and you can
go on to flexible screen allows you to
maintain your steam font here display
but at the dial and the turnover down
Boom by changing up the scale of the
size of the screen to actually fit
something that is very much suitable for
your preference and you can even move it
around the screen to see where you
actually want to put it in most people
are saying you just keep it in the
middle and moving it slightly up and
down to ensure that you get it at the
right spot for your perfect gaming
experience itself so right now I have a
different wallpaper on to show you how
energy looks like when it comes to
multiview function we're having a
landscape mode same thing press up the
up down go on to the multi-view function
and you can see that Samsung has
actually put out quite a few default
settings for you to actually figure out
what type of layouts you want because
side by side you got picture in picture
you've got a bigger frame and two
smaller displays or something that is
more even all throughout these are apps
that you can actually put in individual
sections here but here's the catch
all of all these functions here
you're only able to put in one HDMI
input at one point in time that means
you can put in your PC and your Xbox and
your PS5 settings all at the same time
the problem here is that you can't even
put in things like Disney plus Netflix
or other streaming services do enjoy
while you are using it on your PC
right now Samsung pretty much has only
these few options which is like YouTube
your internet your mobile phone display
and your PC has an additional option
when it comes to mirroring if you can
see audio actually only comes out from
one window here if you have it
highlighted you can still pretty much
operate it as per usual but the tricky
thing is if you want to have audio on
one screen you actually need to
highlight it
and then after that you will be able to
get the audio from that Source itself
but let me show you how it actually
looks like when I lift it up and go into
cockpit mode this is the way you should
be losing this if you really want to
make use of multi-view because
eventually you'll be able to get three
separate sections
in order for you to really enjoy
everything else and get a mobile phone
here let's put on Tick Tock Smart View
this is crazy guys
my head my head is going all the way up
here
just to look at the PC screen zeki's
enjoying this
if you want to even use this tick tock
on full screen itself it's actually
ready for this wow wow
do you need this no but do you want this
yes in some ways yes I wouldn't say you
actually find a very much practical use
to the entire or the CR but it's really
fancy to really Flex as you show off
I'll give that to you Samsung here's the
thing guys if you actually want this to
project on the screen itself you need
mirror cars this Samsung obviously out
does not support Chromecast so if I try
projecting for my pixel 6
you're not able to get Tick Tock onto
the screen itself
taking his Apple phone over there
it's projecting iPhone
yeah screen mirroring you try to
enjoying yeah I can actually just mirror
my whole phone
Samsung what's up the general question
is can you actually use this screen and
a PC screen in a vertical mode you can
oh my God Doom runs in 9 by 16.
I'm not used to this
is so weird if Doom was in a mobile
phone I think the the aspect ratio is
this is weird man I'm getting sick the
funny thing is that when I'm playing the
game itself when I was playing Doom
Eternal it was a bit weird when looking
at the at the aspect ratio of all the
monsters and the creatures it looked
very different to you although settings
wise it was all accurate but I could
tell that something wasn't quite right
it's just maybe something with your
brain or how your eye and has the
disconnect there I think that's the
issue here
other than that it actually works I
couldn't see any real difference and if
this was the reality and imagine that
everything was 9x16 this could have very
well been the reality of how we've been
playing games one of the greatest things
that I came to realize with the Samsung
or the CR is it is actually a
full-fledged TV as well using the main
remote control itself
you actually get a food on themselves TV
experience itself so the entire
exception on this young inference things
like Disney plus and many people don't
realize that how good the speakers are
you can't really get it through this
video itself but I can tell you just by
sitting here and Zach King who's
operating this behind the camera we have
tried it the audio is actually pretty
good you might think hey with all this
space maybe I need a soundbar or
something additional I think this is
pretty much good enough this is
something that Samsung has really no
corners when it comes to the entire
build itself so this is where you use
the uh the normal remote yeah you could
do this we'll just be testing it I think
it's not too intuitive but thanks
Samsung for giving us two remotes so
that we have the option to choose in the
first place we have tested we've talked
around quite a few times here and we're
very familiar with this picture itself
some folks might actually like it a bit
more contrasty or warm or muted you will
need depends down to how you want to
view your content but in general looking
at this over time we found that yeah the
shamans is there but it's still lacking
quite a bit of the contrast and
saturation that we quite like when it
comes to TVs it can't really compare to
the oleds and QD oleds then they
themselves have but let's say if you
want to have it as an all-in-one a
decent PC monitor this gets the job done
so how does it all come together with
Samsung putting the entire display onto
a very heavy base they have created what
they call One Connect box where it has
all your HDMI ports optical audio
ethernet all in one place all of it goes
into the entire box and all the inputs
are fed directly into the monitor
through one single cable only it's
really very elegant solution that I've
seen I think a lot more TV manufacturers
or manufacturers as a whole could
actually explore so the Samsung order CR
who's it actually for we're not really
quite sure at this point of time but but
if you can really afford it at the price
tank of
3299 US dollars or 5000 Singapore
dollars this would be a centerpiece for
your study room or your gaming room
itself I mean after all there are a few
limitations here that will truly make
this really great sound wise it's
awesome but when it comes to actually
the disquality of the display itself
most people to actually lean towards an
OLED or they will actually lean towards
Samsung's own QD OLED pixel density wise
is an 80 PPI not that great when it
comes to working on it for long term
when it comes to tax itself and the size
of the screen I think you're finding a
lot of trouble when finding the right
desk to fit this bad boy on that being
said I'm Gerald from Geek culture I've
reviewed plenty of TVs and monitors and
this will be my last TV and display for
the year itself I'll be looking forward
to checking out even more in 2023 so
check out the rest of my videos over
here